those were different times man i swear
to god like we were all
everyone back then
god it's hot uh yeah we were all we were
all just
wild like you know
yeah now like we've got you know younger
the the the you the new crew of jackass
and yeah dude
they cannot
do what we did back then because what we
did back then was us doing it now times
are different and you you like you can't
really
you can come in with us and hang out
with us but let's not try to recreate
with the things that we used to do
because those things aren't doable
anymore right well especially because
like here we we
cut bam loose because he was like you
know
still doing what we used to do yeah and
now like you can't bring in new guys to
do that no
i mean
in the end in the end let's be real like
this is a business and we we have
characters in which we play sure uh but
outside of what we do on jackass it
doesn't have to be like 24 7 365. we're
not i'm not a jackass i i i used to be
like that though and dude is there
anything scarier than than the idea of
being famous and broke no the like
literally probably the scariest thing
it's not
to be fair and the only thing gnarlier
than to be famous and broke is to be
famous for a bad reason and
because then people hate you
and
you can't get away from anybody because
you're broke so you're just basically
out there and everyone assumes the
minute you become famous or on
television that you're rich i'm like
that's not real like what's real is like
bills have to be paid and just because
you were on tv or a show or a movie or
something doesn't mean that you're rich
and so there are a lot of people who are
who are famous and broke like they they
would like shock you yeah you know but
how could that person not be [ __ ]
killing it and it's just so weird
because like with having the new guys on
jackass and and you know the new girl
like you cannot fault jackass
for
for not giving them like tons of money
because the reality is people would line
up around the entire [ __ ] world yeah
to be in a jackass movie for free you
know like it's like you're handing them
a humongous opportunity by inviting them
to be a part of jackass and you really
don't have to pay them a ton of money to
do it but on the flip side of that when
we get these new people in the jackass
movie we've essentially put them on this
huge platform made them into legitimate
celebrities and
now
they're in this terrifying [ __ ]
position where they really are not
financially secure we weren't either
right like we were right you know that's
80 percent right
we didn't get paid that right you know
let's be honest but you know we did what
we did and you look back now like you
know like you said like you know aaron
you have all this real estate i'm like
well
i bought with the money i made on the
first jackass movie which was like
five thousand dollars or something and
you got a loan i got loan i got a loan
right
you don't feel bad one bit it's like
dude you can make dude if you had if you
you can dude you could become a
millionaire off of ten thousand dollars
like you can do anything it's not money
that's gonna get you there like be
creative
like it does help to have money
obviously and and people might say well
you you you know you you had an
opportunity and like yeah plenty of
people have opportunities and still blow
it and
people don't have opportunity and make
it so i remember when we were filming
the tv show there was like i was so 400
bucks a skit dude i was dude i got 400
bucks i got 200 bucks if it was a prank
yeah they're like a gag and 500 bucks if
it was like [ __ ] life
yeah no doubt like and then and then
sometimes at the first i think the first
season it was that if it didn't air you
didn't get paid
and then after that it changed
yeah after that second season it was per
episode yeah um but dude when we were
filming that first season i was so
[ __ ] broke dead broke because all my
money whenever i got money i owed it to
the cocaine dealer oh god and so like
well you had credit with the cocaine
dealer yeah dude
i i
i had credit whenever i got paid i had
to [ __ ] buy the coke i already
[ __ ] did
but uh
i'm um
we're filming this we're going to like
some [ __ ] fast food place to eat
you know and i'm like hey uh
you know like can you guys [ __ ] you
know get me like a [ __ ] happy meal or
something you know
and they said to me they said to be like
you didn't get any footage today oh
my god
you didn't get any footage today yeah so
you haven't you're out working so
they'll get you a soda water yeah i mean
dude we will not feed you because you
didn't get any footage today
it's a rough business dude it's darling
hollywood like this is a rough business
he makes such a valid point because we
got paid nothing yeah we were [ __ ]
big stars yeah instantly just
yeah so i mean
anybody that's making like a big chunk
of change especially all at once you
have the opportunity to invest it or do
something to them further that money to
and if and if you and if you make a
a choice that you think is a good choice
and and and it turns out being wrong
well at least you thought it was a good
idea like legit you and you thought it
through and it's like you know just
sometimes sometimes bitcoin bitcoin goes
down to twenty thousand dollars let's
just be real
okay
i was like man i was just buying gold at
19
20 an ounce and now it's like 1704 and
danger goes well at least you didn't buy
bitcoin at 60 000.
but dude let me tell you this crazy
story yeah
i i had poopies on the podcast yeah and
uh and he was just like completely
candid he says my bank account is a
negative number okay i'm like beyond
broke like you know and uh we had much
dissimilar conversation and it was
uncontroversial but then
uh my buddy bert kreischer huge comedian
he's got this huge i want to go on his
show he said he was talking about me and
saying some stuff about the cup test
he loved it
i'd love to see bert if you're out there
dude i got you stevo's guide me all
right yeah i got you
so i'm buddies with bert kreischer and
he and uh tom segura another huge
comedian they did this podcast together
two bears in one cave they just cold
called me because they were raving about
how much they loved the jackass movie
and the new guys yeah i listened to that
one so they they called call me i'm like
you know like not just caught off guard
i'm like oh yeah and then they're like
we love the new guys and i was like yeah
dude who doesn't love the new guys and
get this i just had poopies on my
podcast since he's completely [ __ ]
broke can't even put gas in his car you
know
and it was just like whatever you know
like i wasn't seeing it in any kind of
uh you know disparaging way or like
trying to shame anybody it's just like
crazy because here is this [ __ ] movie
star now but that's the reality of
hollywood like i was saying it's like
just because you made it on a show or
something doesn't mean you've made
anything of it i didn't think anything
of it then when that podcast came out
well uh one of our buddies and i won't
like name them to uh you know they give
them any grief but but i got this text
from one of our buddies not a cast
member but someone someone in our world
says what what are you doing going on
this big podcast and airing out people's
financial things he's like but it's just
[ __ ] tacky and it's like and i was
like he's like he says we're the point
you know in our lives and our careers
where we're supposed to be bringing
people up not pushing them down and i
was like but you're not making fun of
his situation you're trying to like help
him along right exactly but i mean it is
kind of like
my response was dude what i was like i
wasn't doing that i wasn't trying to
push anybody down if anything i was
trying to like you know get his story
there you know humanize and help you
know like
galvanize people in in in support of him
you know
and uh it was so crazy because um
then i hear from this guy steve will do
or no i hear from poopies himself he
goes dude steve will do it reach out to
me this is so crazy and and i hit up
steve will do it saying man you hit up
poopy's dude that was so cool and steve
will do it says to me
dude i heard you on two bears one cave
man and like couldn't believe it poopies
didn't want to couldn't put gas in his
grave like i just want to do anything i
can to help him so [ __ ] that is why
poopies was just water skiing behind a
goddamn helicopter with steven who's
like the biggest guy on [ __ ] youtube
you know i ca i i love knocking on the
industry and saying you suck here right
like let's see real you can't [ __ ]
but there is multiple there's a lot of
us sure and there's like you know in the
days 10 of us or whatever and and we're
all the stars like and so
with jackass it's hard but it's that way
with the whole industry it's like how
can i use you
that people take care of each other and
respect each other and love
being able to see that other person
succeed whereas in this industry it
feels like
unless you're succeeding yourself then
it doesn't mean anything to you because
everyone's
very vain like everyone wants to be
the number one in this industry for sure
and and so it's very hard to have like
trust and and care like
in
to trust other people and what they say
and you'll just do whatever like in that
moment like it's like look at us we were
doing it for 400 bucks because we were
on mtv and 400 bucks was 400 bucks right
but looking back now like we should have
got paid a hell of a lot more they
syndicated that stuff
day one like they're made they've made
hundreds of millions of people the tv
show still cranking still cranking just
try to you know think about life as a
long it's a long long game like don't
think of for life being tonight's
ripping party
just remember try and get a plan come
put it together be a good person it'll
all work out in the end
and if it doesn't like work out the way
you wanted it to or the way you
dreamed it just find new dreams find new
goals and never give up and keep going
you know
why their words were never spoken man i
think that clip was awesome but not as
awesome as my new book a hard kick in
the nuts what i've learned from a
lifetime of terrible decisions which is
out september 27th and if you pre-order
it right now you can get the autographed
copy so get on it man pre-order my book
it's not gonna waste your time because
i'm proven dude new york times best
seller my first book's five star rated
on amazon and i have no doubt this one
will be two so get the autographed copy
right now by pre-ordering it at
stevo.com
yeah dude